S
DEFEND THE IDEA OF AMERICA AND
NOT CONCEDE THE IDEA OF AMERICA
TO THE PEOPLE WHO WILL DESTROY
THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THIS IS ONE BIG SKIT
ON I DON'T KNOW WHAT BUT I WOULD
SAY "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" BUT
THAT IS NOT ANYMORE.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH.
CLAIMS THAT IF WE FOCUS ON THE
ECONOMY WHICH THAT IS NOT WHAT
WE ARE JUST FOCUSING ON.
IF YOU SPOKE IN ON THAT
DEMOCRACY IS DEAD.
ISN'T IT MORE ACCURATE -- THAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SOUNDING
DEAD?
>> Speaker Gingrich: I THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS BREAKING
INTO TWO WINGS.
ONE IS WEIRD AND THE OTHER IS
INSANE.
AND FROM THEIR STANDPOINT, GIVEN
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN, A
REPUBLICAN VICTORY IS AN
UNTHINKABLE, HORRIFYING THING.
WE MET CONTROL SPENDING WE MIGHT
RETURN.
TO THE PEOPLE.
WE MIGHT GO FOR OIL AND GAS
INDEPENDENCE.
WE MIGHT LOCK UP CRIMINALS.
I MEAN, WE MIGHT ACTUALLY.
>> SCHOOLS TO TEACH KIDS.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF HORRIFYING
THINGS IF YOU ARE A TRUE
LEFT-WINGER THAT WE MIGHT BE IN
FAVOR OF.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE ANXIETY.
THE PROBLEM THEY HAVE IS THAT
THINK THEY ARE DOING IS WORKING.
I JUST DID A STUDY YESTERDAY
WHEN JOE BIDEN BUT HIS MOST
RECENT ICE CREAM CONE.
IT TURNED OUT THAT IN THE LAST
10 MONTHS, ICE CREAM HAS GOT UP
20%.
SORT OF PERSONAL PERSONIFICATION
OF INFLATION COMING DOWN THE
STREET.
GO THROUGH ITEM AFTER ITEM.
YOU KNOW, YOU WANT MORE
CRIMINALS ON THE STREET.
YOU VOTE FOR FEDERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BIDEN
CONTINUES TO INFLATE THE
ECONOMY, YOU VOTE FOR WARNOCK IN
GEORGIA.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE IRS AGENTS BUT NOBODY ON
THE BORDER, YOU VOTE FOR MARK
KELLY IN ARIZONA.
THAT IS WHY THE NEXT THREE?
YOU WILL SEE I THINK YOU WILL
SEE THE DEMOCRATS GROW MORE AND
MORE PANICKED.
>> Laura: NEWTON THE NEVER
TRUMPERS HAVE SAID THAT, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS ABOUT TRUMP.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BUT DOESN'T THIS ENTIRE
EPISODE DEMONSTRATE THAT IT WAS
ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
IT WAS ABOUT CONSERVATIVES,
ESPECIALLY POPULIST
CONSERVATIVES SIMS.
ANYONE WHO ADOPTS ANY OF THAT
VIEWS IS GOING TO BE TARGETED AS
A FASCIST.
HE DOES NOT ABOUT TRUMP.
IT IS ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
EMBODIES THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT.
IN.
>> Speaker Gingrich: THE LEFT
DESPISE US MIDDLE-CLASS
HARD-WORKING EVERYDAY AMERICANS.
THE LEFT HAS THIS FANCY IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW IF YOU ARE NOT
AMERICAN, YOU ARE TERRIFIC.
WE OUGHT TO HAVE AN OPEN BORDER.
COME JOIN US.
IF YOU ARE A HARD-WORKING
AMERICAN WHO PAYS THEIR TAXES?
LOVES THEIR COUNTRY, WILLING TO
VOLUNTEER FOR THE MILITARY, YOU
ARE SOMEBODY THAT THE LEFT
DESPISES.
THAT IS FAR BEYOND JUST TRUMP OR
NOT TRUMP.
PAPA AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE
HONEST ABOUT THE SCALE OF THE
CULTURAL FIGHT THAT WE IN.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO I MEANT
WHAT I SAID EARLIER.
THEY RANGE BETWEEN WEIRD AND
INSANE AND THEIR IDEAS AREN'T
NUTS AND I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED TO STAND UP TO THAT.
I HAVE A HUNCH WE ARE GOING TO
WIN A HUGE VICTORY IN THREE
WEEKS.
AND I THINK IT IS GOING TO COME
AS A GREAT SHOCK TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
IT WILL BE REALLY GOOD FOR
AMERICA.